dans les villages aux alentours de pieve
le colonel briche et son équipe
d'experts de l'institut de recherche
criminelle de la gendarmerie nationale
viennent constater les dégâts
faites attention suivait bien le chemin
valérie et sa femme vivait dans cette
maison depuis toujours ils ont tout
perdu en quelques secondes
la première explosion a eu lieu ici nous
n'avons pas eu le temps de lever la tête
que déjà il y en avait une deuxième nous
avons réussi à sortir tout était détruit
si nous étions restés ici l'unique de
plus nous serions morts
les témoignages précieux qui viendront
compléter leurs investigations
voici le tribunal de borodianka ou
plutôt ce qu'il en reste dans cette
ville de nombreux immeubles et la
plupart des bâtiments administratifs ont
été détruits avant de se mettre au
travail les gendarmes français effectué
une reconnaissance on va travailler en
sécurité parce que vous voyez que c'est
assez encombré on n'est pas non plus à
l'abri qui reste des munitions non
explosées
autre contrainte pour les gendarmes
français à la particulière et d'arriver
sur des scènes
avec un temps éloigné entre les faits et
le jour de notre intervention donc là on
a peut-être de moi à voir les traces
qu'ils vont être légèrement dénaturer 11
experts ont été dépêchés par la france
chacun un rôle bien précis
spécialiste en explosifs en balistique
en modélisation pilotes de drones
l'objectif figé chaque scène de clim
cartographie est entièrement la zone
afin de localiser exactement les
ateliers que l'on va constater chaque
élément trouver et mesure est répertorié
ni deux côtés l'heure est aux premières
constatations pour le major jean
françois
là on est dans non pas une bombe et un
missile très certainement on pense que
c'est sans doute le plus gros nom colle
iskander qui peut contenir jusqu'à 700
kg d'explosifs les gendarmes sont là
pour collecter un maximum de preuves
chaque indices recueillis pourra ensuite
servir à étayer des dossiers sur les
crimes de guerre commis par la russie
mais la tâche reste extrêmement
compliqué on va pas forcément donné le
nom de la personne qui appuyé sur le
bouton ou à la personne qui a déclenché
le tir l'ukraine comme la russie sont
issus de l'ex pacte de varsovie qui
utilisaient communément les mêmes types
de munitions ce qui fait que à
l'occasion des combats un des deux
belligérants a pu avancer ou reculer il
a pu s'emparer de stock de dupes du côté
adverse et a pu très bien s'en servir
c'est ensuite dans un lieu tenu secret à
kiev que les gendarmes finissent leur
travail l'adjudant chef jérôme pas
modéliser les photos prises par le drone
il aimait genre bien sûr que l'on peut
pas effectuer sur le terrain donc le
modèle 3d résultat ils pointent pour
réaliser ces mesures un rapport est
ensuite établi par toute l'équipe tout
ça est remis à l'autorité ukrainienne
afin que ça puisse être éventuellement
utiliser de moins de juridiction qu'elle
soit ukrainiennes ou internationales
telles que la cpi ou un tribunal spécial
pour l'ukraine les gendarmes de lierre
cgn auront passé six semaines arpenter
les ruines dans toute la région de kiev
analyses et des centaines et des
centaines de bâtiments détruits le
travail à accomplir est encore immense
la guerre est toujours en cours